logan ranks among the very best
superhero movies of all time
and although director james mangold said
he got everything he wanted in the final
cuss of the movie there is still some
fascinating scenes that didn't make it
into the film yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and with the Blu ray of
Logan out now I'm going to break down
all the officials elitist scenes and
discuss some Easter eggs and details we
never got to see in the theatrical
release quick spoiler warning if you
haven't seen Logan yet there will be
spoilers for the movie if you want to
avoid them tap up here for my spoiler
free review and come back here after
you've seen the film there are a couple
of cutscenes involving the mutant
children that Laura and Logan method
Eden first up as a scene with Bobby
a young mutant with electrical powers
who has an action figure of Sabretooth
and another of Wolverine Bobby asks
Logan if Sabretooth was ever real Logan
explains to Bobby that some of it was
true and that Sabretooth was real and
that both he and Victor were developed
as part of a weapons program just like
Bobby was the scene is a nod back to
x-men origins Wolverine where we saw
Wolverine and Sabretooth early history
as brothers
the scene also has an added bit of
hidden meaning as we know from Bobby's
file that the DNA source for his
electrical powers comes from Christopher
Bradley aka bolt and it was Sabretooth
who killed Chris Bradley in origins
Wolverine there's also a tender moment
when Bobby tried to convince Logan that
he's doing good in the world now despite
any bad things he might have done in the
past
and I feel that this deleted moment
would have made the scene later when
Bobby is holding the Wolverine action
figure at Logan's funeral even more
poignant the Sabretooth action figure is
also interesting because during Logan's
development Liev Schreiber was
approached to return one final time of
Sabretooth in a potential storyline
where Logan found his brother Victor in
charge of a major casino many fans would
have loved to have seen the pair
reunited as the performance is an x-men
origins Wolverine are one of the few
bright spots in what has often
considered one of the worst x-men movies
to date
sadly show chilling conflicts and the
way the story developed meant that he is
mentioned in a deleted scene is the best
note we got to Sabretooth in Logan now
there's a pretty dark deleted scene
involving one of the other mutant kids
who director James Mangold is called the
puppetmaster this child uses his powers
of mental manipulation stop Arriba who's
chasing him by making him turn on and
shoot his fellow Rivas and in an even
darker twist the child then makes that
same river turn the gun on himself
after Caliban blew himself up with a
deleted extended death scene where Lowe
badly injured he managed to get out of
the truck and crawl towards Logan in
that scene Logan and Laura lock eyes
with Caliban before he's finally
overcome with his injuries and they walk
away I think this extended scene was
probably better left out as it was
fairly clear in the film that Caliban
wasn't going to survive after dropping a
couple of grenades near himself and if
the scene had been in the film it with
no doubt have seemed odd or even
somewhat callous that Logan took Charles
but not Caliban wisdom however this
cutscene does give a little closure to
Caliban story and maybe highlights that
his sacrifice wasn't in vain and was
acknowledged by both Logan and Laura
actor Richard E grant felt rather
underused in Logan however there's a
little extra deleted scene with dr. rice
where Pierre shows him that he'd
uncovered some coordinates to a location
in the Badlands a reservation on the
border that's also in an x-men comic we
then discover that rice is holding
hostage and Earth you worked an alkali
transition and demanding she explain the
meaning of the comic book and the
coordinate although not totally
necessary the scene does give a touch
more screen time to Richard II grant and
fills in a likely explanation for how
Pierce and rice knew where to find Laura
and the other refugee mutant children a
deleted scene which didn't really affect
the final film sees Logan Laura and
Charles pulled over by a police officer
for speeding after leaving the casino at
Oklahoma City for this moment
director James Mangold was going for the
feel of the road movie Little Miss
Sunshine where the family gets pulled
over by a cop on the journey to a beauty
pageant although the scene is a little
humorous and includes Laura
acknowledging Logan as her father the
scene was nearly two minutes long and
it's easy to see why it got curb the
Munson's family dinner scene also had a
much darker alternative version in the
alternate partly improvised scene
Catherine asked James if he was ever
married and Charles takes over the
conversation saying that Logan was
married one time except that now she's
dead because Logan killed her this
revelation by Charles is obviously
pretty all crystal
Logan and although Mangold has said that
he wanted the dinner scene to provide
some levity this version actually feels
a bit too dark given everything that's
about to happen at the Munson family
home and although according to Mangold
Logan stands alone as an x-men film and
he tried to avoid getting tied down
connecting it to the wider x-men movie
universe this scene might still have
been confusing because the x-men
timeline after Days of Future past
appears to invalidate the first three
x-men movies including Wolverines
killing of Jean Grey in the last stand
so what do you think about the deleted
scenes and were there any you think
should have been in the movie and which
x-men movie or TV series are you most
looking forward to next I'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below and
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to give it a thumbs up and you can also
check out more Logan deleted scenes and
concept art in this video right here and
I'll also have new Wonder Woman videos
coming up this week so make sure you
subscribe thanks for watching and see
you next time
you became movie lovers